under the cover of darkness a Brazilian
black tarantula settles in for a meal
huge hairy and fanged tarantulas are the
largest spiders in the world sometimes
reaching a foot in diameter
with a fearsome appearance and a painful
bite to match roughly eight hundred
tarantula species live around the globe
their preference for warm climates makes
the Amazon the perfect hunting ground
most of them hunt for insects but this
Goliath tarantula measures nearly the
size of a dinner plate it searches for
larger prey
the Goliath impales its quarry with
one-inch fangs injecting a dose of
paralyzing neurotoxins it renders the
mouse unable to struggle or bite back
the tarantulas mouth is unequipped for
chewing so it regurgitates its own
stomach juices over the victim pre
digesting it then sucking up the fluid
tarantulas make their presence known
with size and power but a smaller more
lethal spider hunts in the Amazon and
its deadly reputation is well-deserved
the Brazilian Wandering Spider the name
comes from its nomadic lifestyle The
Wandering Spider doesn't dig a lair or
spin a web it is always on the move
crawling throughout the low-lying areas
of South America from southern Venezuela
to northern Argentina
this spider occasionally wanders into
our neighborhoods meaning it's likely to
cross paths with us
it is infamous for biting when
threatened were surprised and it packs
one of the biggest venomous punches of
any spider in the world in Brazil alone
two similar species account for nearly
half of all reported spider bites the
bite packs a dose of venom more than
twice as potent as the notorious black
widows the venom contains neurotoxins
that immediately attack the nervous
system causing the muscles that control
the heart and breathing to shut down the
venom also contains serotonin that
attacks the brain causing tremors and
intense pain this potent weapon makes
The Wandering Spider a hunter of
incredible power able to kill insects
lizards and mice animals as large as the
spider itself
like a tarantula it prefers to ambush
its quarry using the sensitive hairs on
its body to detect vibrations from
passing prey
once it targets its victim like this
grasshopper the outcome is certain